certains diront que l'instabilité dure
depuis sa naissance mais force est de
constater qu haïti connaît une période
particulièrement tendue ces derniers
mois enlèvement assassinat et
affrontements les images qui nous
parviennent du pays sont violentes
face à cette situation et comme on en a
maintenant l'habitude le gendarme du
monde a son mot à dire
mais sur ce dossier contrairement au
venezuela par exemple washington ne
soutient étrangement pas les
manifestants et préfère s'appuyer sur le
président en place je venais le moïse un
président pourtant très contestée car
l'autorité judiciaire haïtienne estime
que son mandat a pris fin en février
dernier un dirigeant qui glisse vers
l'autocratie gouvernants sans parlement
depuis maintenant plus d'un an
c'est pourtant lui qui a décidé de se
charger de l'organisation d'élections
cette année des scrutins qui pourrait
jeter de l'huile sur le feu tant la
suspicion de fraude est importante
alors c'est en s'appuyant sur cette
situation explosive que 68 membres du
congrès américain ont adressé un
courrier au secrétaire d'état anthony
blinken
malgré cette situation alarmante le
département d'état a insisté sur le fait
que les élections sont la seule voie à
suivre
alors que des élections seront
clairement nécessaire dans un proche
avenir pour rétablir l'ordre
démocratique
nous restons profondément préoccupés par
le fait que tout processus électoral
organisé sous l'administration actuelle
ne sera pas libre équitable et crédible
et que l'insistance continu des états
unis sur des élections à tout prix ne
fera que rendre ce résultat plus
probable
en clair le soutien indéfectible des
américains au pouvoir en place risque de
favoriser l'instabilité politique
et de fait les violences pour le moment
la diplomatie américaine a seulement
exprimé quelques réserves sur le
processus électoral en haïti mais
continue de le soutenir financièrement
au travers d'organisations
internationales les membres du congrès
signataires de la lettre
en plus de vouloir changer le braque
américains dans le pays souhaite aussi
revoir la méthode
parmi les pistes qui les expose la
nomination d'un représentant spécial
pour haïti qui aurait pour mission de
rassembler les acteurs du pays pour
soutenir un développement démocratique
menée par les haïtiens eux mêmes
une initiative qui part sûrement d'une
bonne intention mais qui pourrait se
heurter au rejet de toute forme
d'ingérence par le peuple haïtien c'est
un slogan récurrent dans les
manifestations ou des drapeaux
américains sont même parfois brûlés les
opposants qui sont également mobilisés
au sein de la diaspora haïtienne comme
ici à washington en mars de cette année
c'est donc une grande source
d'inspiration pour moi de voir que des
organisations et des individus manifeste
pour s'opposer à l'impérialisme
américain en haïti et soutenir le
mouvement en faveur de la démocratie
mais pour le moment la diplomatie
américaine semble inflexible et rien
n'indique que l'arrivée de joe biden à
la maison blanche
amorce un quelconque changement sur le
dossier il faut dire que si on parle
parfois de malédiction concernant haïti
frappée par de terribles épreuves depuis
la création de l'état il faut surtout
analyser l'attitude de l'un de ses plus
proches voisins
le pays de l'oncle sam a participé
depuis des années à l'instabilité du
pays notamment par le biais de décisions
d'ordre économique
en 2021 le vent du changement vanté par
joe biden n'a visiblement pas atteint
l'écho des caraïbes